you know in phoenix we got a legend to
us and he is a legend shout out my
brother lifted who produced mercy of
course yeah we used to be around each
other a lot out in hawaii you know right
so he would tell me some of these
stories about hawaii or even like some
of these hotel sessions
up in like some hotel suites out of
london yeah in london yeah yeah
like yeah i just flew in and just kanye
had the studio set up in a hotel suite i
remember it was all in there me lifted
push it was pretty much the whole roster
of good music and they played the mercy
beat and sean was literally sitting on
the floor everybody around him he just
like recording his verse like vibing
that [ __ ] was crazy kanye was like kind
of coaching him like it was a moment wow
yeah so he's just recording it in the
room just sitting on the floor holding
the mic on the floor like just going
over his parts that's crazy
there was another um song
that i may or may not have heard a
snippet of that never has seen the light
of day that was similar to mercy now i
know they put out a mercy part too that
wasn't
crazy but there was another record that
i think was supposed to be what was the
other cruel summer is the one we got
then they were supposed to be cool
winner right winner yeah i mean i i
still got a bunch of beats in my uh zips
that say cruel winner ideas like i was
presenting ideas for crow winner because
i had three or four songs on cross
summer
that's crazy
did you hear any of the cruel winter
[ __ ] um
we just i mean probably probably stuff
that could have been on there